There's so much that we don't know.
And I know that we have been saying
a version of that for many, many weeks.
But I would just like
to remind people that
the word that people,
you know, supporting
Trump were putting out
yesterday was fanning
the flames of reports that the grand jury
was out for a month.
So I think there's a lot of twists
to take on this.
He is now going to go through the process
of getting arrested.
And I think that that is going to be
much more jarring for him
than I think people realize.
I've been told that he's been briefed
on what that will look like.
It will involve fingerprinting
It's going to be unlike,
you know, a normal arraignment
because he's going to have Secret Service
and this is going to look different.
This is somebody who has spent
more than four decades
trying to avoid being arrested
or being indicted.
And so this is a really scary moment
for him, despite whatever he says.
Now, you talk
to different people tonight.
You hear he's fine.
You talk to others who say that he's
very angry.
I expect that we will be hearing
all of those emotions
going in various ways
for the coming days.
I don't know what the fallout
is going to be politically.
And I think this is the first time
that I can think of where he can't
he can't control this.
He was able to control impeachment
in some way because Mitch McConnell
was on his side in the Senate trial,
because House
Republicans were on his side.
He was even able to control
the second impeachment to some extent
with the Mueller report
and the investigation.
He was never going to get indicted
as a sitting president.
And I think that he has an overconfidence
in his ability
to impact events by intimidation
tactics, by pushing out headlines.
This is now
in the hands of whatever judge he draws
and what the voters think.
There's
so many potential ripple effects
on public perception voter perception,
it's it's impossible
to kind of game it out
many steps in advance.
It is in part because he's such a
an agent of uncertainty. Right.
I mean, if you think about the fact
that we had a week of a news cycle
that he created by saying
he was going to get arrested on Tuesday,
which literally
no one was saying in the news media,
and he created that.
And then when that
you also fundraised office
and he fundraised off it.
And then when that day came and went,
he said, look, you know, it's
all falling apart. It didn't happen.
So I don't know how
he's going to handle this.
I do notice that,
you know,
he did not reiterate his call
for protests.
I thought that was pretty striking.
I did notice that Elise Stefanik,
a very close ally of his,
put out a statement
saying that people should organize
peacefully.
And everyone is trying to stress
that around him
because there are still these echoes
of January six. 20, 21.
Yeah.
And I think it's also something
we should note.
We were talking about earlier
that we've both heard from people
is that they genuinely had an idea
that this may be falling apart,
that it may not actually be happening.
This is from Trump's attorneys.
There are a lot of attorneys around him
at the moment.
He's hearing
from a lot of different voices,
but that is why they were
so caught off guard
by how quickly this transpired today.
Yeah, they had
they believe
the grand jury was not coming back.
They believe that this was not going
to happen for a month.
And then others of them,
not all of them,
but others of them did believe
that the case was falling apart,
primarily on the word of Bob Costello,
a Giuliani lawyer, and briefly,
Michael Cohen,
either lawyer or legal adviser,
depending on who you believe,
who came in as a defense witness
in the grand jury in New York,
that you have the right to do that.
There was no
evidence that
they ever offered
as to why they believe
that, just things
that people were hearing.
And as I said,
Trump likes to create headlines
that he thinks influence events
that obviously did not happen here.
And if anything, frankly,
all the stories yesterday
about how the grand jury
was going to be off for a month
probably alleviate
a pressure valve for Bragg.
It sort of
it took the heat down a little bit.
I want to bring in David Urban
and in Van Jones.
David,
I mean, this is a remarkable
historic night
and wondering what your
your thoughts are on what happens now
Yeah.
So, you know, Anderson,
I was just thinking back
20 years ago
when I was a
chief of staff of the state Senate,
and you had the impeachment
of Bill Clinton and Bill Clinton
you know, was impeached
and was acquitted similar
to President Trump
and then remained in office.
And there,
you know,
Ken Starr went away
and special
prosecutor Robert
Ray was still lingered around.
And there was the threat of
of Clinton being indicted
when he left office.
That was always kind of out there.
And the day
before he left in January, 19th, 2001,
a former special prosecutor,
Robert Ray, cut a deal with President
then President Clinton to
to not prosecute him. Right.
And to let him surrender his law license
for five years,
pay a fine and put it aside.
And, you know,
there was a great deal of pressure on Ray
to indict him at the time and
and he didn't.
And he said,
you know,
the American
people and history will judge me
and judge
whether I did the right thing or not.
And in retrospect,
you know,
I think Robert Ray did the right thing,
and I'm not so sure.
History will be so kind in this case
to Alvin Bragg.
Van Jones, what do you think
Well, I think that,
you know, Democrats,
progressives are swinging back
and forth
between being very, very worried
and very, very relieved.
You know, on the one hand,
geez, you know,
this case is hanging on a novel theory.
It's not the insurrection.
It's not the coup.
It's not the election interference.
It's a hush money payment.
There's worry that this is
maybe not the bridge
to try to die on at the same time.
I think a lot of people are saying
finally, finally, something
has happened
to get some kind of accountability here.
You've had our social norms
run into the ground.
You've had our political norms
run to the ground,
at least our legal norms
are not being run into the ground.
In this case,
you have a prosecutor
who went to everyday,
ordinary Americans and said, here's
what I've got.
Do you think it's chargeable?
And they said, yes,
And I think that there is a sense
among some people
that somebody had to do
something at some point
and that everybody's
just kind of standing on the edge
of the swimming pool,
looking at all
these prosecutors, all these these cases.
And nothing has happened to happen yet.
And so on the one hand,
I think people are concerned
and they're worried
and they hope that this
and set some precedent
where presidents start
is getting prosecuted.
There's real concern.
But there is a sense
that finally some kind of accountability
may land on the doorstep of Donald Trump.
John Miller, it's
going to be interesting when,
you know, we're able to look back
and know
exactly what happened
in that grand jury room
over the last several weeks,
because clearly the the last witness
that was supportive
of the former president
or at least critical of Michael Cohen
made it seem to affect the course of
of the grand jury in some way.
I mean, when you talk to people
in the district attorney's office
who have been following
the plan of the grand jury presentation,
they expected to get that indictment
back on Monday,
I think the 13th of March, two days ago.
Right.
Putting Bob Costello in as a witness
in place of Donald Trump,
who they invited to testify
on his own behalf and declined
seem to be something
that they planned to do.
And then put it
to the vote of the grand jury.
I think
we don't know
what effect Costello's
testimony had on the grand jurors.
That that is something
that's only in their minds.
But we know the effect
it had on the prosecutors,
which is they
thought he did damage to their case
and they didn't
want him to be the last thing
grand jurors heard
before they went to a vote.
And the people I've been talking to said,
you know,
they went in two days of strategy to say,
what do we need to put in front of this
grand jury to repair that?
And so doubt into what Costello said.